[Musik]
Foreign
Lyanna Wir haben gerade von dem zweiten
Feuer gehört, das gestern passiert ist. Die
Situation wird immer schlimmer.
Was weißt du, wie das
gestern Abend das zweite Feuer passiert ist
?
das
zweite Feuer
Über das erste Feuer haben wir eine zweite
Information
äh da gibt es Flüchtlinge die sagen
das es mit Tränengas angefangen hat die Polizei
warf
es war jetzt die zweite Nacht die die
Flüchtlinge ohne Zelt schlafen müssen
ohne ein Zuhause
wie verbringen sie das  die Nacht verbrachten sie
die Nächte auf der Straße
ohne Zelte viele von ihnen keine Decken
sie aßen nichts sie hatten kein Wasser
sie hatten keine Windeln für ihre
Babys
nichts sie haben nichts i
okay manche Leute können sagen, dass sie
nichts hatten  bevor
du es weißt wie maurya wir alle wissen
was in
den letzten fünf jahren in diesem camp los war
eine gesunde situation wirklich schmutzige
kinder die mit dem schlamm spielten maurya war jetzt die schande
der menschheit in europa
sie haben nicht einmal diesen
kampf, wer ihnen jetzt hilft, das problem ist, dass nicht einmal die ngos
sich dem gebiet nähern können,
wir haben bewohner aus den umliegenden
dörfern, dem dorf moria und
anderen, und sie blockieren die straßen, die
sie nicht wollen die ncos  Um ihnen zu helfen,
blockieren sie die Behörden,
das Militär oder irgendjemanden, der
große Fahrzeuge zum Wiederaufbau von Moria schickt,
damit Moria nicht gebaut werden kann. Diese Leute
können nicht nach
Linnytown oder anderswo gehen, sie stehen einfach
irgendwo
Brandstiftung Die Regierung sagte, es
gab Proteste vor dem Brand, weil
die
Begierde im Lager verbreitet wurde. Was
wissen Sie darüber
? Gibt es Anzeichen für Brandstiftung?
Es gibt Sehenswürdigkeiten für unseren Sohn
Sie sagten, das Feuer habe
nach den Unruhen begonnen, den Unruhen zwischen
Afghanen, Arabern,
Syrern, Somaliern, aber es gibt einen Streit
darüber,
die Behörden und  Einige Flüchtlinge
sagen, dass das Feuer von den
Flüchtlingen ausgegangen ist, aber neben mir habe
ich jemanden, der mehr darüber sagen kann,
und er hat die ganze Situation miterlebt.
Er sagte, dass das Feuer von der
Polizei
ausgegangen ist. Können Sie uns ein bisschen mehr erzählen?
darüber, wie das Feuer angefangen hat,
ja, als erstes kommen die Jungs zum
Zelt und sagen,
diese Familie hat die Ecke, und die
Familie hat gesagt, wir haben keinen
Colonel und wir sind nicht krank, und dann
sagt die Familie, bitte geh, und dann
gehen die Jungs  und die Polizei kommt ins
Lager und
schießt sie erschießt die Wachen und
macht das Feuer und spannt alle Tests aus
und alles, was sie kommen, ist das Feuer hält
alles fest, dann zündet das Feuer an
und trifft sich am frühen Morgen,
aber die Regierung kommt nicht ins
Lager und
zu einem Feuer und dem Wasser im
Inneren, äh, lassen Sie mich das
klarstellen,
also hat die Polizei das Feuer entzündet,
ja, ja, nein, Polizei, Polizei, schießen das Gas
und brennen die Zelte ab, dann haben sie die
Zelte verbrannt und das Feuer angezündet,
aber es gab  drei feuer ja das ist
der erste tag
erstes feuer ich glaube ich sagte das erste feuer
du weißt wo die leute bekehrungen
und die polizei das gas ins
camp schießen und ihre zelte verbrennen und
eis eisböcke verbiegen also war das erste feuer vor zwei tagen
vom  Die Polizei
und dann andere Flüchtlinge haben andere
Feuer gelegt,
ja, und wenn sie ihre Wachen
im Inneren des Lagers erschießen und anfangen,
stoppen sie
das Feuer und verbrennen alles
und jetzt, was Sie tun werden,
wohin Sie gehen werden,
wissen wir nicht  Wir haben keinen
Platz und wir haben keine
äh Situation gut und du kannst
meine Kinder nicht sehen Wir haben keinen Platz Wir haben
keine Decken Wir haben keine Zelte Wir haben keine
Wir haben keinen guten Platz,
wir sind kein Tier, Sie kennen die
Regierung, Griechenland,
denken, der Flüchtling, der Migrant, ist ein
Tier  Flüchtling kann nicht in
ihre Stadt gehen, wohin  du
willst jetzt gehen du willst
in lesbos und griechenland bleiben oder willst du
woanders hingehen
wie deutschland oder wenn wir wenn wir
äh als wir mein land verlassen haben
äh weil wir keine äh sicherheit
in meinem land haben
auch wir nicht  Wir haben keine Sicherheit in den
Murien, Sie wissen, wir haben keine
Sicherheit in Griechenland.
Wir müssen Europa dabei helfen,
einen
Flüchtling in ein anderes Land zu bringen. Bitte
, wenn Sie Menschlichkeit haben,
helfen Sie uns bitte,
denn wir sind keine Tiere  wir
lehnen ab
Sie wissen, dass wir Flüchtlinge sind, wir haben
keine Sicherheit für mein Land,
und wir kommen wegen der Gesundheit hierher, wir
haben nichts,
nichts, was wir nicht haben,
bitte, bitte helfen Sie,
wenn Sie nicht können  uns, denn
wenn du
die Leute nicht sehen kannst, kannst du die Leute
auf der Straße sehen,
zwei Tage schlafen die Leute auf der
Straße, und wir geben kein
Wasser, geben kein Essen, wir haben nichts
zwei  Tage sind wir hungrig und wir können nicht in
die Stadt gehen,
kaufen, Lebensmittel für meine Kinder kaufen, jetzt, meine
Kinder  Ich muss nicht
nur wissen, meine Kinder, vielleicht
zehntausend oder fünftausend Kinder
, die wir
in diesem Lager haben, wissen Sie, haben Sie auch
keine Milch, haben Sie nichts,
vielen Dank,
keine Eilmeldung, niemand hier  ist das nächste
Video und Vergebung